is a journalist who has looked carefully
into this story and joins us tonight to
explain thanks so much for coming on so
just starting with the premise if you
control a country's enemy energy supply
you control that country where's the
united states moving
well i mean our problem here is that
everything in within
our entered
the biden administration's approach to
how we fuel our country right their
whole climate change agenda we it makes
us reliant on china for all the sources
of energy so take for instance solar
panels
they aren't manufactured at least into a
degree that is necessary
in the united states they are mainly
manufactured in southeast asia and in
china
unfortunately the biden administration
recently put a tariff on them so all
these solar panels
that are across the country just have
the rods sticking out there's no panels
because we couldn't get them from china
he recently lifted that however it's
going to take a year or two for those
panels to get here and the problem with
the panels are not only are they made in
china um but even if we made them here
in the united states uh we need the raw
minerals from china to make the panels
so they wouldn't again we are totally
relied on relying on china to make our
energy
sustainable under this climate change um
mandate
yeah so it's a chinese takeover of the
united states i mean i don't know why we
don't call it that and i think going
forward we will celine zito thank you
for reporting on that
thanks for having me
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight